People who don't know what violence is.
It's like,
here's one that people say.
They'll say to a martial arts person,
like they'll see someone like a John Jones.
Like if I was John Jones,
I just fucking kick everybody's ass.
Like,
no,
you wouldn't.
No,
Okay.
Do you know and all the problems that Jon Jones has been in,
one thing you should notice is never been in a fight.
There's no street fights out there with John Jones.
You know what I mean?
I would bet he has least the least likely person to engage in that activity.
I bet you're right.
Yeah,
because he doesn't want to do because he knows exactly the consequences,
let alone the legal consequences of doing it outside of a cage.
Exactly.
But when you look at it from someone who has zero understanding,
they're like,
oh,
if I was that guy,
be kicking everybody's ass.
But no,
you wouldn't.
Because like violence,
people don't just accept violence.
You don't just hit someone and get away with it.
They think about that shit forever and they try to get you back and either hire
someone to get you back or they get you back on their own or they wait for you
to not remember it and then they,
they come around the corner and fucking brainy with a baseball bat.
This is what people do.
People don't like getting fucked up.
If you kick someone's ass,
they're going to remember it.
They're going to,
and this idea that you're going to be able to suppress people buy by attacking
them and hitting them with bike locks and you know,
and not letting them speak at universities that,
you know,
you're,
you're protesting at,
it's,
it's madness and it's,
it's so confusing because it's not indicative of what I always thought of when I
thought about left wing people.
I thought there were peace loving people or well educated and instead you're
getting these people that are from their fucking computer,
they're calling for violence.
Like you don't know what violence is.
One of the thing is too,
from what I've seen,
it didn't start with the bike locks,
right?
It started with,
you know,
shout this person down and then it's like fist fights and then they're throwing
rocks and then it's bike locks and now I hear people,
you know,
get your guns and it starts to rise to that level.
I'm like,
okay,
yeah,
you people need to calm down because the theory of it,
we need a revolution in this country.
Like let's pump the brakes,
homeboy.
Well first of all,
here's what we need.
We need camaraderie.
We need to be nice.
This is more important than anything.
We need to be calm with each other.
You know this,
this idea that yelling people down stops anything.
You're just going to make people yell louder on the other side that that shit
does not work.
That's not how human beings operate.
When if you want human beings to appreciate your perspective,
find the things that you agree on and work towards a better humanity.
Work towards a better,
more loving way of interacting with each other.
This is possible while disagreeing and this is one of the most important things
I think that we could ever express in terms of how to communicate with each
other.
You don't have to shout people down like the the best way to do it is to try to
figure out the points that you can agree on,
find out what you disagree on and find out why you disagree on it and you're
always going to get bad actors.
Right?
You're always going to get people that are in there that they don't care.
They're not reasonable,
they just want to win and well then there's a giant problem with that kind of
communicating because it's so absolute.
It's my way or the highway like that's,
that's where violence comes from.
That's where that's where real.
Yeah.
That's where real physical conflicts,
that's where they come from.
When there's no way to negotiate.
There's no way to communicate outside of that.
I just think it's,
I dunno,
bizarre is not the right word.
I think it's sad that the vast majority from,
again,
my opinion,
what I see is people who are identifying with shit.
You can see on the street sign.
Yeah.
Like left or right,
right,
right.
You're telling me that as a species,
that's his nuances.
We can get you want to completely define yourself and your ideology and your
beliefs by something literally you can see just driving your car,
turn left,
turn right.
It's just,
I don't understand it.
I don't,
um,
it's the exact opposite world to go back to,
you know,
getting out of the military and,
and,
and just kind of entering into the world and like what's going on.
Yeah.
Makes no sense to me.
It makes me extremely uncomfortable.
I hate hearing people calling for violence.
Um,
I know,
and especially calling for violence when it's not necessary against the
Americans.
When you,
what you had to deal with in the military has to be the most intense form of,
of conflict that's available on planet earth.
The most intense form of conflict is war.
That's the real conflict.
That's real consequences.
You've suffered them physically.
You've seen countless friends saw for them physically.
That's the real shit.
So when you seeing people from universities from these coddled environments and
these,
these people with it really an completely ignorant perspective as the,
as to what the actual consequences of violence are calling for it.
It's just bananas.
On one hand,
I'm glad that they haven't experienced it because I can tell that they haven't,
just by the way that they're acting and I'm glad that they didn't have to do
that.
But on the other one,
it's a tough pill to swallow because
I just don't unders war war is a,
uh,
it's about as high consequence as you can get for sure.
Like I said,
it resets your,
it resets your perspective.
And the last thing that I would ever want to see is that here on the streets of
the u s like I,
I just,
I can't even imagine how destructive,
well,
it would just,
it would destroy our country for sure.
But I also don't,
I can't figure out and the route out of where we are.
So people are calling for violence,
right?
It got other countries trying to incite a get groups together.
Like,
what's the navigatable route out of that?
Mushrooms
hadn't considered that route.
I don't,
I honestly don't know.
Um,
I'm hoping that things don't have to come to a head.
I'm hoping that we don't have a Kent state or some,
some horrible event in this country were,
you know,
protesters and,
and the people that oppose them get into some horrible deadly violent encounter
cause so far other than Charlottesville,
that time that guy ran over,
uh,
the woman in the car,
we're seeing most of this violence being at least somewhat contained to
fisticuffs.
Right.
And you know,
the,
the professor to hit that guy with a bike lock and there's a few other instances
of people get knocked out and punched and hit with sticks.
We haven't seen mass shootings and murder,
but God dammit,
that Shit's close.
Especially when they're doing rallies and people are like,
you know,
yeah,
let's do an open carry rally.
And everybody show up in their operators sheikh apparel with,
I look at the pictures of that.
I'm like,
okay,
you have a lot of stuff.
First off,
that's on fucking backwards.
You know,
like I'm looking,
I'm like,
okay,
you have all the tools,
but you obviously don't practice with them.
But the danger of just,
you know,
what's the next step?
First,
we're just gonna,
you know,
we're going to where?
All of our stuff.
All right.
Well if it started at fist and then when bike locks and then when show up with
your civil war gear,
right.
What's the next step after that shooting?
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't want to get involved in that.
I mean,
I,
well you picked a good spot where you're at in Montana.
Where I live does not suck.
Yeah.
Hang out there and move in.
Once the first few rounds have been fired,
the dust starts to settle.
I just,
the problem is I would want to come off the bench.
Of course,
the problem is if that happens and I'm not,
I guarantee you I'm not the only one that feels like that.
I'm going to get involved and it's going to be a serious problem for those
individuals because,
uh,
I'd give my military career,
see across the board average,
there's absolutely nothing spectacular about my career.
I had done more than some way less than others,
but I've sacrificed enough that I'm not gonna allow those people to tear us
apart.
But it's the last thing on earth that I want to do.
But they put me in that position.
I know that myself and many other people are in that same boat are going to get
involved.
And that's,
I don't know if that's going to help the problem,
but it's going to get ugly pretty fast.
Remember a time where the country spins so divided in terms of,
I mean,
I don't know whether it's because of social media and because of the Russian
influence on social media compounded with having Trump as a president,
compounded with,
I mean,
people that feel like they're disenfranchised and they,
they don't feel like they're like,
you know,
you hear about this all the time in regards to income inequality.
People feel disenfranchised.
They feel like the system has failed them.
And that's why so many young kids are favoring socialism and why so many young
kids are moving towards that.
They think that anything has gotta be better than watching these fat rich cats
with all this money controlling the world.
And that the only way to get out of that as revolution,
but damn,
you're,
you know,
like there's a lot of people that are not those fat rich cats.
You're positioning yourself against it or just normal regular Americans who
happen to be conservative,
you know,
in conservative does not always have to equal racist.
It doesn't always have to equal white supremacy.
It doesn't always have to equal all the negative connotations.
You know,
religious fanaticism and all these different things that people always attach
towards conservatism.
It doesn't have to mean that it couldn't,
it could just mean people who are a prudent with their finances,
who are,
you know,
they're,
they're cautious with the way they think.
They're more conservative in their values and their ideals.
This is,
that's not a bad thing necessarily,
but we've got it lumped into these two groups left versus right.
And there's a very little gray area,
but it's the tyranny of,
or you know,
it's like it's as if there's only two choices.
You're either left or right.
Yeah.
Like where's the end?
Where's you trend to the left?
And you also have some values that are associated with the right,
or you're trending at that.
It's a.